[Music]
Okay. So about four years ago, our path
crossed and he's popularly known in the
eastern region for cultivating crops
like rubber, cocoa, and plantain. is an
interesting get together again. And
today we are not just going to talk
about the old things but something new
that has happened which has to do with
coconut nursery production. And seated
next to me to tell me more about this
business and what got him into it
iswamiame and
[Applause]
aka I don't want to mention that oneame.
Nice meeting you again. Nice meeting
you. Oh my goodness. It's been 4 years
already. Yeah. So, how has it been? It's
been great. It's been great. I
understand the difficulties we all have
in this country, but we all count. I'm
counting my blessings. It's been great.
Great. Great. Let's refresh the memory
of those who might not have seen your
story four years ago. Um, your schooling
days in UK and then you got back to
Ghana and then refused to go. When we
want to go, me I want to go.
Let's get to know briefly again who
Kqaame is for the purpose of those who
have not seen the interviews we've done
four years ago.
Uhwame I'll simply say somebody who is
so passionate about agric
um I think coming September will be my
12th year of being being in agriculture
being a farmer 12th year right so I
think the journey started somewhere in
2012 when I decided to go into rubber so
currently I have about 94 acres of
rubber then I moved into cocoa which I'm
doing about 160 acres of cocoa mhm M um
I like the challenge so I decided to
take on something very different and
that is coconut. So um I think among all
these two three um the three cups that
I'm planting coconut is something that I
really enjoy. Oh really? And um yeah I
think I really really enjoy doing
coconut. Okay. Um not just because of
how sweet coconut taste but I I think
it's a lovely tree crop. Okay. And I
think people need to really understand
more about coconut. So I mean we here to
just breathe. Awesome. Awesome. Awesome.
Um talking about a sweetness and a
lovely crop. Is that what made you got
started or something else? Um I think
it's more of diversification. Okay.
Where I was looking at diversifying and
looking for something different to do.
Um as I said the first focus was to do
rubber then cocoa. I've done a lot of
things you know. I don't really want to
talk about it like in vegetables almost
a lot of things but I think um I chanced
on coconut I mean where I realized was
something that Ghanaians were really
patronizing so the interest I mean got
to me so I decided to just um diversify
into coconut as well okay and how will
you describe the experience so far it's
been great um I know a lot of people
want to get go into agriculture and I
would say coconut is um somehow one the
easiest treatment. Okay. Um I mean I say
easiest not to say that it's easy to do
but then if you follow the right
procedures and the right methods, it's
not that difficult. Okay. And then a lot
of Ghanaians are I can I realize we are
we don't have the time. Most of the
people who want to go into agriculture
one way or the other don't have the time
to be a farm throughout 24/7. Exactly.
Um I think coconut is one of the farms
that you can have where you can be a bit
absent because it doesn't really demand
you know doesn't demand a lot but then
as I said you need to get it right okay
you can't just do it anyhow you know you
can't just do it I understand with all
the three cups having it been cocoa
coconut guava mango cashew it all
demands time lifewise coconut but then
with my experience I think it's one of
the things that most people can invest
in where they can feel very relaxed and
you know visit the farms as to when they
make the time to go there. So yeah a lot
of people are interested in coconut
farming um especially because of its
profitability and also the endless
benefit that you get from coconut.
However, most people also get it wrong
especially when they are going to buy
the seedling for planting. And so I want
want us to touch on how can a novelist
or even someone is already into farming
but want to diversify like you have
done. How am I able to identify a hybrid
and non-hybrid coconut seedling? A very
good question. I would want to go back a
little bit to share how I even got into
coconut nursery. Go ahead. So I think
2017 that was when I wanted to embark on
um having a coconut farm.
Um, fortunately I I like to do farms on
a large scale. I don't really believe in
2, three, four, five acres. Not to say,
okay, if you want to have an acre
coconut farm is bad, but then I was
looking at doing coconut up to about 200
acres. Okay. So the seedling selection
as to what exactly I'm planting was
something I was very very interested in.
Not to say there weren't nursery
operators around. I saw a lot of them.
Yeah. But then when the right questions
I call it right question because I did
my research I I asked they are not able
to really give me the answers to the
question that I'm asking them. So I
think it was a bit difficult for me when
it comes to um um getting my siblings
for my coconut farm. You know like the
rubber was easy because um right where I
have my rubber farms there's a company
RPG rubber plantation Ghana so they have
the siblings. at the cocoa farm you know
we have a subsidiary for cocoa that's
the um SPDC production department who
goes to the um producing the seedlings
for us but with the coconut I realized
there was nothing like that you know so
that's when I met one um aonomist Dr.
who I met you know through research.
Okay. Who explained things to me um who
gave me some numbers then I embarked on
it. Yeah. But prior to that I still went
ahead to purchase some few seedlings
from some few natural places but
subsequently I started nursing my own
siblings in my farm just to transplant
them into my field into the field.
Exactly. So I think I had a lot of
interest. I mean when people came to the
farm they saw my siblings and are you
selling them? Are you selling them? And
I started giving them um exactly what
got me to start this nursery. So with a
lot of experience the question going
back to the question you asked me how do
you identify between the hybrid the
hybrid because I get it a lot when you
go to a typical um nezri or n operator
who is selling coconut. I mean the the
first question people ask is I want
hybrid. I want hybrid. I want the one
that that germinates within that start
producing food within three years within
five years and it's a very difficult
it's a very good question but how do you
it's kind of impossible impossible to
identify a hybrid seedling by just
picking the nut. It's impossible because
you have to be in the farm you have to
see the tree to where the nut is coming
from. You can easily identify a hybrid
tree. So out of the hybrid tree, you get
the hybrid nuts. And I was a bit shocked
because mean you go out there to the N
operators asking them is it hybrid? They
will tell you yes, it's hybrid.
Sometimes it's true. I'm not saying and
I'm not trying to say that they're
lying. But how are you sure these are
hybrid seeds? So that's when I was a bit
excited because I was picking my nuts
from a hybrid farm. I was producing my
own nursery for my own farm.
So I I have all the benefit a hybrid
farm can have in my farm. So you can't
identify unless you're in the farm.
Sometimes you can try to use the the
overallness of the of the of the nuts,
but it's still not doesn't make any
sense to me. You have to be in the farm,
okay, to really know whether this nurses
it's hybrid or not. You have to be in
the farm to really identify. M if not I
don't see any way you can identify
between a hybrid and another hybrid farm
not a hybrid there's no way it's
practically impossible so you have to be
in the farm see the tree and that's why
so let me go back to it usually when you
read more about coconut they will tell
you that it's it's better and it's ideal
to nurse seedlings out of a farm that is
about 20 years plus it's not because of
anything one you So when you have a a
hybrid farm that's about 20 years, you
can clearly see its features. You can
see the nuts, you can see the tree
itself, right? You can really identify
that is hybrid or not. Okay? Cuz if you
start using coconut that is about five,
six, seven years when it starting to to
cultivate as a cultivar to cultivate um
produce leisurely, it's kind of
difficult to identify it. So usually
it's better that you have a farm that is
about 25 30 years. Most of my farms, you
know, and to to add it up, I I hardly
produce I don't even produce my nurses
in Ghana. Okay. They all from Ivory,
okay? You know, and most of my farms are
uh usually 60 years, 40 years, 35 years.
Okay? And you can see a 35 year old farm
that has that height, okay? And you can
easily identify and they'll tell you
this same farm is 35 years, but it's not
hybrid. You can see how tall okay the
the whole farm is and let me just
butress with and end it with that
question that why do people even want
hybrid signals why why hybrid does it
mean the other nurseries are not good
they are good they're equally good but
you know the term hybrid I mean hybrid
in the sense that anything hybrid is
kind of is taken through a process where
one is a bit resistant to diseases one
is a bit robust is susceptible to
diseases and all that And the most
important thing about hybrid is hybrid
coconut is the maturity. Okay. As to
when when you plant it and how long it
will take to get the fruit. So I think
that answers the question. You need to
be in the hybrid farm. Okay. To know
that this farm is hybrid before you can
pick a nut. If not, it's impossible.
Okay. So what's the capacity of this
production center? Yeah. Currently here
we have we had about 40,000. Okay. But
we've been moving them out. So now we
have about 20 27,000 over here. Okay. So
what we have here are they all hybrid or
nonhybrid? All hybrid siblings or pure
proper hybrid siblings. All right. And I
I think I I want to backress with this
where I even prefer people to come to my
farm. You know I have 170 acre coconut
farm. Oh yeah. Sure. So usually when
people come over here, I tell them you
don't have to even listen to all that I
have to say to you. But if you have the
opportunity, visit my farm, see what
I've done, then you can at least speak
to it. Okay? It's all hybrid. Pure
hybrid. Okay. Now, when you drive around
Ghana, you see bits and pieces of
coconut here and there. Some tall, some
short and all that. But where do coconut
grow best in Ghana? in what soil and
what are some of the regions you can
mention? A very important question and
you see um farming is supposed to be
taken very serious and sometimes it
baffles me when people get up one day
probably make some money and you know
they just want to plant something not to
say I mean Ghana you can plant coconut
everywhere but there are ideal locations
there are there are places where it's
better let me talk about the soil so
with spoil soil you're looking at a well
drained let me just well drained sandy
soil okay and to say sandy soil I know
when we went to JSS they thought about
the properties of a sandy soil exactly
where it's loose right it's not sticky
you know it's not sticky it's loose it's
it's it has a very low I mean low water
retaining capacity what it means is it
can drain water pretty fast okay um
coconut does well in a well drained
sandy soil Okay. And not to say that the
other lands can't thrive well with
coconut. It can. Okay. But then just say
you want to do coconut on a very large
commercial scale, thousand acres, 500
acres. These things are necessary. You
can't just get up and say you have a,000
acre land. So you want to start planting
coconut. So you just start. No. So I I
believe that we need to do the right
thing when it comes to agric. Okay.
Because it's expensive, right? And we
get frustrated when it doesn't work, but
then because of the the things we take
for granted, we have to be very careful
when it comes to choosing a site for
coconut. As I said, it's practically
possible for coconut to thrive in any
part of our country. But then you're
looking at production, you know, you're
looking at production. That's why
specifically it stated that well drained
sandy soil you know is best and ideal
and to the regions the regions you know
um it has to be a place where rainfall
pattern is massive like you know a very
good rainfall areas. So talking about
the central the central regions and all
that is ideal and that is where we get
most of the coconut from the western
regions as well they are all close to
the coastal side. So realistically can
conclude by saying yeah all the sand
soil within those areas are almost you
know not to say coconut doesn't do well
let's say like a region coconut would do
well over there but it's a bit different
you barely find the right sandy you know
the sea kind of land around region it's
better to do it over there as well but
on a large commercial farm you need to
really take in consideration what kind
of land and just to add up Um, it's not
necessarily you have to do your test.
Mhm. You see, Ghanaians, I realize cuz I
meet a lot of farmers. Let me just tell
you what happened about 2 weeks ago
where a farmer, I call him a farmer. No,
he doesn't live in Ghana. He lives in
Canada. And um he got my contact. He
called me and he's been calling me to go
visit his farm. Okay. He has about 60
acre of coconut farm somewhere in Oda.
And I couldn't make it cuz I was very
busy. Yeah. So he was sent to Ghana
somewhere in May and um he called me
that when he comes if I can get
opportunity to visit. So yeah I he came
around and we visit his farm and to my
surprise the things I saw over there was
a bit like this is very serious you know
and the farm is about six seven years
and it's very poor. So from I think he
got it wrong from from eating the
seedlings. They got it wrong from the
planting distance. They got it wrong
with the soil. They got it wrong with
everything. Oh my. So you see all the
investment that he's putting he's put
into this farm with the time and he is
okay. He doesn't really need much. He's
just excited to be a farmer. But then
it's so depressing to to to go through
something like this. So I think the
right questions needs to be asked. You
know the right soil needs to be you know
used when you're getting into coconut
farming. You just don't get up and say
coconut does well. People can even plant
coconut in water you know in water mashy
areas. No you don't it's not done. Okay.
You know coconut is just like any other
tree just like cocoa. It needs a well
like a well you know very good soil to
go very well. Yeah. So I think
that's a place
where the soil is more sandy a very good
pattern. Coconut needs a lot of water,
you know. Not to say the water should be
retained around the coconut, but the the
soil should be able to drain a lot of
water. It shouldn't hold the water.
Exactly. All right. Right. So I'm sure
you're seeing a lot of interviews about
coconut on our channel but this has
become very important for us to
reiterate and you know educate you
before because most of you are wasting
money or losing very very good amount of
money uh because you lack knowledge
because you don't have the right people
to buy from I'm going for a quick
breather when I come back will tell me
more about if I have just one acre and I
want to go into coconut production or
farming
How many seedlings will I be needing to
actually do my one acre farm? I'll be
right back. Stay
[Music]
tuned. Thanks for staying. If you're
just tuning in, you're watching the
Ghanaian farmer. We encourage you to
share your views globally. If you're
watching us, you have any question, you
have any contribution, share with us.
But this is about how you can identify
the quality, the right type of coconut
seedling to buy for your farm. Don't go
waste your money and come back crying.
But before went on break, I was asking
if I have just one acre, it's a test
case and I want to go and plant, how
many nuts are we looking at? Okay. So,
an acre of coconut with a spacing of 7.5
m and that is actually an ideal spacing
7.5 m and that's about 25 ft. Okay. Will
be able to accommodate about 705 trees.
Okay. 70 to 75 trees, right? Uh most
people come and they will tell you, I
have an acre. I want to put about 120.
You advise them no too much. It doesn't
work that way. Okay? you know uh what
you put on the ground is what you get.
So that is the preferred and required
you know um um um planting distance and
the quantity that is used. So at a
distance of um 7.5 m apart um um that's
about 25 ft. Okay. You have close about
70 to 75 trees. Okay. On an acre of
land. Okay. Is there a special way of
planting coconut in the soil? Is there
any special way? Yes. Um there isn't any
special way you know I think when it
comes to general farming a lot of people
probably will show you how to do this
how to do that but you would have to try
and find something that works for you
okay you see we don't have irrigations
in Ghana we don't even irrigate our
farms right so finding a means to plant
coconut that will sustain it that will
help a tribe better sometimes you would
have to try and coin your own
You understand? So what I do
specifically usually I mean I consult
for a lot of farms and I help them in
planting their coconut you know coconut
we even call coconut as um a thirsty
tree cuz it needs water. Not to say that
there there's supposed to be so much
water around it but it needs water at
least every 2 weeks after planting it
needs to be watered. Okay. So um there
isn't any special way of planting
coconut. um sometimes when it comes to
general farming. Yeah. And that as I
said, I've been a farmer for the past 12
years. Every September was my 12th year.
And sometimes my friends don't even
believe that. You would have to find
your own way. Coin your own way. Do
things you think is working for you. You
don't you don't just go out there and
watch a video on YouTube someone doing
something and you want to replicate that
same thing. You know, the lands are
different. M so try and find ways and
means to to do things you think is
benefiting you. So one of the things I
do when I'm planting coconut is how I
dig my hole. Okay. You know I dig the
hole such that it's so big where I have
a lot of space around it. Put the
coconut in the middle. Yeah. Cover the
soil. Yeah. Cover the coconut with the
soil. But then there's still a lot of
there's a lot of space around it. What
does that do? See, we don't irrigate our
fun. Yes. And see the rainfall patterns
are pretty poor sometimes. So you need
coconut. As I said, coconut is usually
called the testy tree. It needs water to
dry very well. So leaving that space
around the coconut tree when it rains
sort of like you have some water
collected around it. So it means if it's
not going to rain for even a month or
even two weeks, you have that space
around the coconut being very moist
which will aid in proper growing of your
coconut tree. Okay. So there isn't any
kind of like special way of planting
coconut but you do things that will help
you things that will make your farm do
well. So you need to find ways. As I
said farming is not something you can
learn and say you are done learning. You
learn every day. You keep learning. You
keep learning every day. So there isn't
any special way as in somebody trying to
tell you it can work. If somebody is
trying to demonstrate something to you
it mean the person have tried it but it
doesn't mean when you try it it's going
to work for you. Okay. So that is my
way. try and dig the hole that big. Put
the coconut in the middle. Leave a bit
of space around it where there will be
some water collected when it rains. At
least if it's not raining. Yeah, it will
still use that water. Okay, that's
interesting. I've not seen that before,
but I can't wait for him to demonstrate
for us to see. That's a tip for you. So,
when it come to the nursery, if I buy
the nuts, how long does it take for me
to start seeing the leaves shooting?
Great. M so we start coconut by picking
the dry nuts. Okay. Usually it's
advisable that the nut drops themsel you
know it's usually not advisable to climb
the tree to pluck dry nuts. Um in terms
you it has to be well dried before it
can germinate. Okay. If it's not well
dry it will never germinate. Okay. So
usually when we go to some of the farms
that we we we start our nurseries from M
um usually we don't have enough nuts so
we are forced to climb the trees to
pluck some of the dry nuts and to our
surprise um over times the nuts start
gating even on top of the tree. Oh
really? You can see it protrudes just a
little bit. Okay. Whilst it's still
hanging on the tree and then that's one
of the difference between the hybrid and
the non-hybrid seedlings. I think the
hybrid seedlings have a very soft shell
sort of where germinations are pretty
easy. So if you happen to have a nut
that is already germinated, it means
easy to go. It means within some few
months, it goes really fast. But the
germination is a problem. There are
times you can go under a typical tree,
you have about let's say 100 nuts, dry
nuts dropped. Yeah. Out of these 100
nuts, you can have let's say 30
germinated. Okay. And it's just natural.
It's not something out of anything.
Yeah. you know, so you have to notch it.
Usually we call what we call notching.
Notching is where we cut just a bit.
Okay. Let's pick one that you've cut. So
something like this. Okay. So we notch
this coconut. You know, coconut has this
shell. Yeah. Where when there's water
poured on it, it will just drop off.
They won't get into the coconut. You're
trying to force water into the coconut
to aid germination. Okay. So the whole
idea of notching where we cut a bit of
this space is to get water into the into
the coconut where it can aid fast
germination. Okay. Right. So when
germination starts it takes close to
about 6 months transplanting it gets to
the height where you can transplant the
coconut. Okay. So from let's say from
the time you pick the nut to
transplanting it's about 6 months. Okay.
Yeah. So what it takes 6 month here
before a farmer comes to buy. Exactly.
Oh my I see. Okay. So when I'm coming to
buy the nuts to go and transplant, what
time of the day do you recommend I come
by to to buy my nuts? Yeah. Um this is a
general question where I'll answer for
all tree crops. Okay. And these are the
mistakes we do as farmers as well. Yes.
Tree crops, you know, mostly
predominantly in Ghana, we don't
irrigate them. Okay. What it means is we
plant them early part of the year when
the rain setting. Yeah, there isn't any
particular day as in planting in the
morning or in the afternoon but it
should be planted early I mean the month
we know somewhere in April May we start
getting rains in Ghana okay it's ideal
to plant any tree okay be it rubber be
it cocoa be it cashew coconut
very early what you're trying to do is
to help this tree crop to establish very
well so it means when you plant them
early let's say you plant it by May
you're done planting your seedlings. It
means it gets all the rains. That's you
know we call them the Ghana we have the
major rainy season and the minor.
Exactly. So the major rainy season is
usually between April, May, June, July.
Then we have a bit of a drought. Then
August, September, October, November we
have the minor rainy season. So if you
plan early, it means you have all this
rain from you know May, June, July all
the way through to about December. Yeah.
So, you have a wellestablished tree
crop, whether being coconut or cocoa or
something like that. I I get a lot of
people who come around somewhere, you
know, in September and they want to buy
seedlings to go plant cuz we start
nursing seedlings somewhere September,
October. That's when we start doing our
preparations. And I tell them, it's not
ideal because you're not sure cuz we are
entering the minor, we are in the minor
season and there's going to be drought.
Yeah. So as to a specific time of
planting, no but it needs to be planted
early. At least your land preparation
should start early. You know by January,
February, March, you should be done. You
with your land preparation by May you
have to finish planting your seedlings.
Okay? And that will help you have a very
good um seedling growing for for you.
But what if I have irrigation? That is
also okay. But you know there is
something different. There's a big
difference between natural rainfall and
irrigation. Yes, you can't 100% rely on
irrigation, especially with tree crops,
you know, it doesn't really need a lot
of water. If you can add irrigation to
your tree crops like coconut, there you
go. It's excellent. It's ideal. You can
you can you can it does really well.
Okay, you know, but then because you
don't want to spend so much money,
sometime not say it's not necessary,
it's very necessary if you have the
finances to have an irrigated coconut
farm. It's a plus for you. All right.
But then if you plant it early and it's
well established by November, December,
why you don't even need any irrigation?
In that case, how long then after my
transplanting will I be waiting to start
plucking and selling or enjoying my
coconut? Yeah, I I get this question a
lot. A lot of questions people come over
here. My brother, how long am I going?
You know, I heard there is one that even
someone even said there's one that is
even two years start getting coconut.
Coconut. See, um
And this not to say anything. Coconut as
I said earlier thrives really well in
sandy well drained sandy soil, right?
And with the hybrid seedlings you're
looking at between 3 to 5 years. 3 to 5
years. In my farms, in some of my farms,
I demonstrated where when I planted the
seedlings, yeah, when I transplanted, I
took I took note of it when we did the
transplant. Um in one of my farms about
5 acre farm like a plot where I
demarcated and did the planting
we realized that we had about 60% okay
of the seedlings giving us flowers after
the third year oh about 60% okay you see
when somebody comes over here probably
they want to buy like one seedling or
two or three and buying three seedlings
and planting them and expecting maybe
for it to give you fruits in let's say
three years and four years it's usually
not realistic. I say it's not realistic
because if you're doing a whole a whole
plantation like a big farm you know the
soil nutrients is completely different
from each part of the soil like it's
land you can have a big land but the
nutrients at one particular spot is
completely different you know so it's
usually proper and ideal to have some
quantity of seedlings where you can now
be very sure that are these really good
quality seedlings you can use one
seedling or two seedling that you
planted in your house as a yastic to say
it's not a good quality seedling maybe
the soil that you even planted the
seedling on it it's not good it's not
good quality right and you ask how long
I said 3 to 5 years I know with the
hybrid seedlings after the third year
you see signs of flowers okay you see
signs of flowers after the third year
but let me add this it doesn't matter if
you buy a hybrid seedlings and you don't
go through the proper
things you need to do for the coconut to
thrive well. Okay. Everything needs to
be met. You know, proper planting,
everything has to be equal. All right.
So, if everything is done well, I mean
farming, somebody say farming is too
risky. Of course it is. Everything is
risky. Everything is risky everywhere.
If you can do it right, if you can do it
very well, be guaranteed that at least.
And if you know you are buying a right
proper seedling it's a very important
and that's one of the things people
neglect not just with coconut in
everything we do having it being
vegetables or anything you know you have
people it all start from the seed.
Exactly. You need the right seed to get
the right you know I mean whatever the
outcome is to get something better out
of it. So why compromise on the on the
on the initial initial I mean nursery
you don't compromise. Cuz if you
compromise on the nursery, everything
you're doing, whether it's 2 years or 3
or 5 years, is all compromised.
Struggle. Okay. Since you have a coconut
farm, you should be in the best place to
tell me how many fruits am I likely to
get on one plant? And of course, what
would be the lifespan of a coconut tree?
So, um, ideally it varies from region to
region. I said when I go to Ivory Coast
where we start our nursing and I see the
kind of farms they have with the kind of
maintenance they are giving the farms
and you see the typical coconut tree
with a lot of nuts on it.
I can't say you can have that same thing
probably when you plant it. That's why I
said it varies from origin.
on the average when the coconut is
starts after let's say the fifth year I
mean it's so tender and so young on the
tree to carry a lot of trees I mean
coconut a lot of nuts at a time you know
it's so tender it's still young so it
can't hold a lot of I mean coconut you
know coconut is very heavy exactly so
when they are very young you don't
expect much but in the full maturity
we're looking at between let's say 5 to
15 years when the coconut is well
established. You are confident that you
should you shouldn't have anything less
than 100 nuts in a year. Okay. In a year
between 70 to 100 on one on one tree.
Okay. 70 to 100 and it can go all the
way to 150. I went to a farm and I
counted not less than 120 120 nuts on
each of the of the tree that I Oh yeah.
Okay. I counted not less than 120 nuts
right on each tree. But as I said, you
can't say because you have 120 when you
come by the seedlings and you go plant
it, you also expect to have 120 your
care, your maintenance, your farm
practices. The soil is a big
determinant. So it's not always about
what you do. Sometimes you do everything
right, but you still not get that, you
know, expected um, you know, what you're
looking for. You probably want to get
130 a tree, right? But then I know that
at least a poor farm that is probably
taken care of. I mean a poor soil that
is well probably taken care of, the
right fertilizer and all that. I mean I
think you should probably get something
above 70 to 100. Okay. Per tree for a
year. Okay. A year. Okay. And the
lifespan will be how long can a coconut
tree coconut usually we call it the
three generation. Three generation means
when you plant it, your kids will come
eat it and your kids kids will come eat
it. Usually they say about 60 70 years
but then it can go more than 100 years
but you know in in in farming there's
something called viability
it's not economically viable after some
years because probably you be giving it
too much care too much attention where
the fruit that is giving you can't
complement how much you're making out of
it so it becomes not economically viable
at some point I mean I'm sure maybe
after 70 80 years it's proper to
probably start a farm all over Okay.
Yeah. Okay. Do coconut need fertilizer
and are there any specific fertilizer
that coconut need? Yes, coconut needs
fertilizers just like any other tree. Um
people say yeah. But then um I think one
of the easiest
um um um fertilizers you can find around
which is available is a chicken man. It
responds so well to chicken. Okay. Yeah.
Okay. I don't think it's a heavy feeder
fertilizer. I don't think so. All right.
That's why it's a very robust plant.
That's why I like it. It's robust and
it's not too difficult to do. Okay. So,
with just a little fertilizer, as I
said, you can do the some of the
inorganic fertilizers. Okay. The MPKs
are all good for coconut. But I prefer
people doing more of the organic where
they can embed a lot of the chicken
manure around the coconut. You know, it
keeps that space around the coconut very
moist. Okay. Cuz it likes that. Yeah. So
in as much as you can give it fertilizer
like the NPKs like the 1515 it's also
okay to give the organic money like
inorganic man inorganic um fertilizers
and to add it to butress it do you know
we give coconut salt salt drink is it
the big ones or the adan salt okay so
you wonder why coconut thrive so well at
the shop yeah exactly keta adan you have
coconut and they are there for years. So
coconut does well having given it salt
because you probably will bring coconut
to your farm, there's no salt content in
the soil. So I I read extensively and I
started doing it in my farm and I saw
the response. A lot of people complain
so much about my farm is not doing well.
There are too many um um diseases here
and there and I think salt is a cure. I
see. It all depends on how you apply it
apply it. We would go to his farm for
him to show us that Exactly. Because um
and this is something that
um yeah I consult a lot sometimes for
free. I like I love to do it and people
have so many issues on their farms and I
get there and it's something very simple
simple okay something very simple to do
you know and because usually they are
not there and they leave the farm for
farm managers to take care of them
they're not able to identify this salt
plays a very good role in coconut by
applying it around the roots. Some you
can even put a little bit of you grind
it and put a little bit into the leaves.
It does really well. Okay. You mentioned
disease. Are there any disease that
affected coconut? How do I prevent or
cure it? Great. So um um coconut I
realize usually predominantly it's um
the root rot usually caused by fungus.
Okay. Um coconut is sweet. So you have
every every insect like you know even
rodents Yeah. attacking coconut. It's a
sweet I mean crop so you need to really
take care of it very well. One of
the diseases that I find easy attacking
coconut is the root rot where usually
when you're planting the seedling um you
have a bit of termites and some you know
in the soil. So they end up chewing the
the the the root which to prevent the
coconut from growing it ends up killing
the coconut. So the root rot which there
is a way to to to solve that issue with
the root root rot and I see more of
people complaining more of the wevils
you know getting into the like you know
the middle part of the coconut chewing
the middle part that is supposed to
germinate that's supposed to grow very
well I mean there are easy ways to kill
these things but then just to add it up
I went to somebody's farm who was
complaining about this issue of
having you know chewing
their coconut. But I go to the farm and
the farm was all bushy. A lot of weeds.
Okay. So you can't cail these weevils
whilst you have a lot of weeds in your
Exactly. Where do you expect the weevils
to go when you treat them? The moment
you treat them, they will just jump into
the the next one. The bush. The bush
where they will hide. Yes. So your
coconut farm should be free. Okay. And
it's a basic principle.
The moment you can keep it weight free
where there aren't many waste you won't
have a lot of insects hiding into into
the bush which will end up going into
your coconut to to call it. So sometimes
it's not really about focusing so much
on the coconut, but it's about focusing
so much on the kind of things you need
to do in the farm, the maintenance, the
reading, right? It's not really about
the coconut cuz as as I said, the
aronomic practices are very key. Okay.
So once I have to wait for 3 years plus
to start harvesting my first fruit, is
there any form of or any type of crop I
can intercrop with my coconut? And at
what stage of the coconut am I allowed
to do my intercropping? Very very good
question. Very very good question.
Um I understand Ghanaians usually don't
have a lot of farm lands. Yeah. So they
like to intercrop cropping we call it.
Um yes coconut you can do some
intercropping. Yeah. But it has to be
some specific crops. Okay. And I would
generalize by saying vegetables
things like tubers like cava. Yum. Nope.
Okay. I don't subscribe to those things
because they are so heavy feeders on
fertilizers. I mean sorry on nutrients
on nutrients.
So I usually don't subscribe people
intercropping tubers or cripping plants
like you know within coconut but
anything like vegetables um vegetables
like tomatoes, garden eggs, okra these
can be planted within coconut. Okay. And
it can be done right after you even
plant plant a coconut, you know. But as
I said, not to say that casaba will have
anything bad on coconut. Yeah, I visit
somebody's farm like that. He's planted
co I mean casabas throughout his farm.
Okay, he has a big farm and it was full
of cassaba. And I told him, boss, it's
not done. And he said, nothing has
happened to my farm. And I said, nothing
will happen to your farm. I'm not saying
the cava will kill your coconut. It
won't kill it but the cassava will
deplete the soil so much that no matter
no matter the fertilizer you introduce
you introduce to the coconut it won't do
well. Okay. You know there are some key
nutrients in the soil that is not
replenished. You can replenish them. It
takes time. That's why we have what we
call the pharaoh period in agriculture.
Exactly. You just have to leave the soil
to just stay on itself and it just
regain it. You can never introduce any
fertilizer to get that nutrients that is
lacking in the soil. That's why I say
it's not advisable to plant crops like
cava, yam and other things in the
coconut. Let me just backress by saying
coconut needs sunlight. Okay, sunlight,
plain sunlight. You go to people's farms
and you see coconut under trees,
under shades, coconut need at least 6
hours of sunlight. Okay. So it's not
something
you have to go through the processes and
if you do it well you enjoy it. Are
there any challenges associated with
coconut uh production? Um just as I
mentioned earlier with the diseases that
can be eliminated somehow it can be
controlled and it needs to be controlled
early. Um apart from that I would say
the drums um usually as I said you have
to plan early. Yeah. So if you plan
early your chances of having a
successful farm is higher but then if
you have to wait and plant start
planting somewhere September October you
know not to say it's bad but you're not
sure exactly of the rain patterns. Yeah
if you have irrigation that you asked
earlier that is okay you can plant it
and you know you can irrigate your your
seedlings when you when you transplant
them. So these are the challenges that
people face. It's expensive. It's not
cheap. M it's not cheap. So I not even
the nurses farming is expensive and I
expect people to do it right. Get it
right from the start and you enjoy it.
In as much there are frustrations in it.
You don't want to be frustrated so much.
So try take your time. If you're not
ready, don't even start. I tell people
if you're not ready, don't start. It's
okay to say I want to start something
small. But then have it in your mind
that even that small thing is
challenging.
That small that you want to start is
challenging. So be ready, be emotionally
prepared before you get into
into okay. I know you are into the
farming and the nursery production but
give and take. If you are asked to make
a choice, will you stick to the nursery
production and forfeit the farming or
you you do the farming for you one not
both. So I I I I
I wasn't really looking forward to
having a coconut nursery. Was never part
of my plan. I never even envisaged or
thought about it. Okay. Um so I remember
somewhere 2020 when I started my nursery
in my my time. Choose one. When I
started my I had this agree director me
and he saw my ne and he loved him. Okay.
and he told me just do a lot of this and
without you know and I was a bit
hesitant but then I started doing it and
it's giving me the opportunity to you
know what advise people tell people what
to do the farming practice and all that
I'm sure if it was just my farm I
wouldn't have that opportunity so it
makes it very difficult and you need to
have the farm okay and have the nursery
to compliment because if somebody comes
over here you usually I like them to
visit the farm so they
before they come. All right. Okay. How
much is one? Call me. You don't have to
say this on. Okay. Okay. Okay. So, so,
so um let us know your location and how
we can find you. So, we have we have
three nursery sites. We have three
nursery sites. One in Bas
um not too far from We have one on the
Asaman stretch. um that is at Samanu
stretch and we have one in Kofaridia.
Okay. So we have nursery sites in all
these locations and we supply
nationwide. Okay. Right. We supply
nationwide. Um people within our inkling
let's say within eastern region usually
we do what we call free distribution
free supply when you purchase from us
some quantity. And um we also don't only
sell we give consultancies. Okay. We
advise people on what to do and um yeah,
as I said, if you buy some quantity, you
do free delivery. We do. Your number,
please, so that we'll be able to reach
out to you.
22574 Yeah. And we're here for you.
Okay. So, that's
it. Thanks for mentioning the number and
how we can reach out to you. But finally
any tips or advice to give to those who
are already in it, those who are yet to
start so they can get it right because
you had said it already. It's expensive
being small or big farm. It is
expensive.
Yeah. Uh simply put, I would say get it
right from the start. By getting it
right, it means the right seedling. Ask
the right questions when you're going to
buy the seedlings, you know. Um
everything not just even farming starts
with the how you started but farming
specifically is with respect to the
seedling that you're planting being a
plantain being a cocoa being a coconut
so you need to get the seedling right
the neur has to be right and when we say
get it right I mean you don't really
have a lot of control you probably won't
have the opportunity to raise your own
neur I did for myself that is really
successful for me but then wherever ever
it is you're purchasing your seedlings
from, try and ask the right questions.
Cuz if it's wrong, if you get it wrong,
then you're doomed. Then it's going to
be very difficult for you. So ask the
right questions and and and I think you
can be very successful at being I mean
get into coconut farming. Yeah. And I I
inreat I intreat people to get into it.
Um as I said earlier that coconut
happens to be one of the farms to me. I
know people will dispute that that you
can do and relax but that is if you can
do it well well properly planned farm
where you don't necessarily have to be
in the farm always okay unlike some of
the other tree crops I'm a cocoa farmer
and I know what goes into cocoa it's
tedious it's very difficult right rubber
farm before I started tapping rubber is
so tedious but coconut unfortunately is
not that difficult and I I I relied on I
I I say it's not difficult because of
the things the processes that are put in
place studing well planting
well pegging well even the lining and
pegging has been done very well and if
all these are met you are in for for a
very beautiful journey in coconut okay
and um coconut is good I entreat people
to go into it yeah okay so let's use
just one acre for an example um how much
am I likely to make out of one acre
coconut farm. Wo. Wo. So, um,
coconut I would say is lucreative, okay?
Cuz it's a demanding commodity. You
know, people drink coconut everywhere in
Ghana and it's one of the things that I
can bet you that when you plant it, you
certainly get the market for it. So, um,
like like I said earlier, an acre of
coconut, you're looking at around 75
trees,
75 acres. And I said earlier that a tree
can give you maximum. It can give you up
to about 150. But being realistic, we
can limit ourselves that okay, you're
going to be a very good farmer. You go
through all the right farming practices.
So you're targeting to have at least 100
nuts per tree for your coconut. Let's
just use that average. But as I said,
it's not 100. It can be even less. That
is depend on how you take care of your
farm. But let's say you are a good
farmer. You're going to go through the
right processes and the right practices
to probably get at least 100 per tree.
So, simply you can multiply 100 nuts by
75 trees. When you do that, how much how
much do you get? 100. Uh, please wait.
You know me, I like money. 100 multiply
by 75 trees. Hey, how much is that? How
how many siblings are that? So, it means
you're going to get what? 7, 500 nuts.
Yes. A year. Yes. I don't know how much
in Ara times I buy coconut for six
cities. Ah, it's CD. Sometimes I buy
five cities. No, it's CCD. Right now,
they've read budget. Exactly. So, let's
say let's say you're not even going to
sell it yourself in you just looking for
let's say half of money. So, you're
probably going to sell it for even half
of that price for three cities. So,
multiply 7,500 by three by
three. Hey, it means you have what?
22,500 per acre of coconut. And this is
you doing an acre five trees. So if you
want to do let's say 50 acres. Yes. You
multiply 22500 by 50. How much do you
get?
Hey 1 billion. One means you make 1
million 1 million 1 million00. The G
people say 1 million. Exactly. It means
you can make a million cities out of
coconut. 50 acre coconut farm. But there
are conditions to it. Of course it's not
that it's not magic. have 50 acres and
you make 1 million cities, you can make
a million cities out of a 50 acre
coconut farm. But it all depends on what
you do to the your management. The
management is a key. It plays a key role
in your success. Okay. Yeah. All right.
So, you know what we're going to do? I'm
going to organize a webinar forwame and
myself so we can delve detail because
there are still questions I wanted to
ask him. you know this goes live on TV
here in Ghana and then you watch the
rest on YouTube so let's consume this
information okay and then we would
organize a webinar for uhwame he has
rubber he has coconut cocoa and many
other things let's do a webinar so he
enlightening us all the questions you
have you would meet him one on one and
then we'll conclude with my name is Nam
this has been the Ghanaian farmer his
number was mentioned in the interview
take your time pick the number call him
and he'll be there to help you. Thank
you very much for watching. Thank you
very much for having us. Thank you.
[Music]